classrooms with universal mask wearing
cdc continues to recommend at least six
feet of distance
between teachers and staff and other
adults in the school buildings and
between these
adults and students in common areas in
the school
when masks cannot be worn such as when
eating
during activities such as singing band
practice sports exercise and other
activities that
inc can increase exhalation these
activities should be moved outdoors or
to large well-ventilated spaces when
possible
and six feet should also be used in
community settings
outside the classroom today's
announcement builds on our
ongoing efforts to support teachers
school
staff and students as well as our work
and educational and public health
stakeholders to provide the guidance
tools and resources to get our nation's
schools
open as quickly and safely as possible
this includes our plan to invest 10
billion dollars to support covert 19
diagnostic and street screening testing
for teachers
staff and students which we announced on
wednesday
and our ongoing work to get teachers and
school staff vaccinated during the month
of march
through more than 9 000 pharmacy
pharmacies in our federal retail
pharmacy program
that are now prioritizing vaccination
appointments for teachers and staff who
work in k-12 schools
if you're an eligible educator or school
staff member and have not yet been
vaccinated i encourage you to go to
cdc.gov
to learn more about how you can sign up
for an appointment through this program
i'm hopeful that we are turning a corner
on this pandemic
getting our children back to school
in-person instruction
as soon as possible is a critical first
step in doing so
i'm grateful to all the scientists who
produce the evidence to address the key
question
such as the distance required to remain
safe so that we can move
quickly to this end thank you i look
forward to your questions and i'll now
turn things over to dr fauci
thank you very much dr welinski i'd like
to spend the next couple of minutes
in addressing an issue which is on the
forefront of the minds of
many people and that relates to the
threat
of a variance of concern particularly
the b117
variant which right now as we know is
causing a significant degree of concern
in europe where the flare and the surge
that they are seeing
is directly related to the variant one
one seven this variant as you know
is every day getting more and more
dominant
in our own country so very first let me
take
just a few seconds to refresh your
memory about the variant
it was first detected in the uk in
december of 2020 it was reported
in over 90 countries the first u.s cases
were detected in the united states in
colorado at the end of december
of 2020 and since then it has been
detected in 50 jurisdictions in the
united states
and likely accounts now for about 20
to 30 percent of the infections in this
country
and that number is growing next slide
so i want to do again is take a look
first of the concern that we have
and then some encouraging news and then
i'll end with a caveat
of concern is that there are about 50
percent increase in transmission
with this particular variant that has
been documented
in the uk and there's likely an increase
in severity of disease if infected with
this variant
next slide this is an example of that if
you look at the daily confirmed cases
in certain selected european countries
over a period of time and as you can see
the last date on this slide
is march 17th this
is what i referred to previously about
the surges
that are going on in europe at a time
when we've reached this point of
plateauing
that dr walensky mentioned to you where
we're now
at 53 200 cases
per day on a seven day average this
strongly suggests
that there's an increase in
transmissibility in the european
countries
associated with 117. what about
severity of disease next slide in a
couple of uk studies this
one looking at over 54 000 matched
pairs of participants in the uk in which
one person was infected with the b117
and another one with the previously
circulating variant
there was a 64 increased risk of death
for those with the b117
next slide in this similar study in the
uk
there was about 5 000 deaths that were
analyzed
where there was the presence or absence
of 117 and again
an estimated 61 higher risk
of death with b117 next slide
what about some encouraging news there
has been a minimal
impact on viral neutralization by eua
monoclonal antibodies and importantly
for what we are doing in the united
states with vaccines
there's been a minimal impact on viral
neutralization either by convalescent
plasma
or importantly by post-vaccination
sera next slide and so on this last
slide
as you can see with israel as an example
where the b117 predominates as their
vaccine doses into the arms of
individuals
increase you're seeing a very dramatic
and steady
diminution of cases which is
underscoring
the effect and the capability of the
currently utilized vaccines
against 117. with that encouraging note
i want to end with a big
caveat the way we can counter 117
which is a growing threat in our country
is to do
two things to get as many people
vaccinated
as quickly and as expeditiously as
possible with a vaccine that we know
works against this variant and
finally to implement the public health
measures that we talked about all the
time
and that was on dr welinsky's slide
masking physical distancing and avoiding
congregate settings
particularly indoors i'll stop there and
back to jeff
thank you dr falchi and uh before
before we open it up for questions i
spoke at the beginning about reaching
the president's goal to administer 100
million shots
in his first hundred days and we
accomplished that in just
58 days this week we've also announced a
number of steps to help deliver on the
president's goal
to get our schools reopened
as dr wolinski just discussed the cdc
continues to work to update its guidance
for schools as the science evolves
earlier this week we announced that
schools will receive 10 billion dollars
in funding for testing programs
and nearly a hundred and thirty billion
dollars to help schools invest in
litigation strategies like ppe
additional space hiring more teachers
and at the president's direction we're
also working to get all
educators vaccinated with that we'll
open it up for a few questions
all right and i know there's a lot of
questions today so please keep your
questions to one question first we will
go to ann flaherty at abc
hi thanks for taking my question uh dr
malinsky can you address the criticism
by some of the unions that
the research that you're looking at in
schools does not address
underfunded urban schools and on the
testing
you've encouraged testing but these
tests these rapid tests are not widely
available on the market
even with the additional 10 billion
dollars
how soon before schools can test
yeah thank you for that question and um
you know we have now
increasing evidence from many different
uh school settings that did not control
for ventilation
um as to demonstrating that it is safe
in classrooms 100 mass to be at three
feet
um and so i you know what i would say is
you know we're we are following the
science and we have done the science
and we've uh seen the science to make to
ensure that this is safe
for those schools our strategies for
mitigation the layered mitigation
strategies that we have demonstrated
talk about distancing
masking as well as respiratory etiquette
hand washing and contact tracing we have
added
indeed layered mitigation strategies um
further layer mitigation strategies for
both ventilation as well as testing and
teacher vaccination
so while we don't believe those to be
essential all of those are scaling up
simultaneously through the american
rescue plan
next question next we'll go to aaron
billups
at spectrum news hi thanks for taking
my question so a growing number of
studies are finding that
the second shot of the mrna vaccines are
unnecessary for people previously
infected with kovid19
um in france they've changed their
policy based on this
are there any discussions happening to
consider a change in dosing policy for
the u.s in light of these findings
particularly because research is showing
that second doses are effectively wasted
on those
with pre-existing immunity
yeah yes there's no doubt that for the
preliminary studies that we have seen
right now that vaccination of an
individual who has been previously
infected
a much greater increment in the
level of neutralizing antibodies
compared to an individual who has just
been vaccinated and received a second
dose
now obviously the places that are now
looking at that
are those that have a true paucity
of vaccine doses but as you've heard
from
jeff just recently we are now at a
position where we are giving between two
and three million
doses a day if there were a dramatic
shortage i think that's something that
you would want
to consider but that's not something
that we'll be making a policy about soon
thanks and importantly we have enough
doses now driven by the president's
action
for all adult americans by the end of
may
next question
next we'll go to michael wilmer at
mcclatchy
thanks everyone for doing this uh i'd
like to ask about these fema run
federal mass vaccination sites and
clarify some confusion i'm hearing
that's out there
in florida we understand that the sites
are now transitioning to
only administering second doses uh
and will then close up shop so two
questions
specifically one on florida are those
mass
sites closing and then secondly and more
broadly
are all of these federal mass
vaccination sites intended to stand up
for only
a couple weeks at a time thanks
you know i don't know the specific
specifics on florida we can follow up on
that
but i can say across the board these
sites are really an important
uh opportunity to increase the number of
places where
americans can get vaccinated and as i
said in my opening comments we're now
well over a million
shots doses administered at the federal
sites
the federal sites are seen as uh very
well run
and importantly not only efficiently and
effectively
delivering vaccines but doing so in an
equitable way
so the plan is for the federal sites to
continue
uh we'll get back to you with any
specifics on the florida site
next question next we'll go to caitlin
collins at cnn
thank you very much i have a question
for jeff and a question for dr wolinski
jeff can you just explain what is what
do you mean by
loan when you're saying that we're
loaning back vaccines to mexico into
canada these ash
brazilian vaccines does that mean that
they're going to
reimburse the us for these or return
this amount of astrazeneca doses could
you just explain that
and then dr wolinski could you say was
the cdc
pressured by teachers unions not to
change this guidance
to three feet from six feet in schools
so so thank you caitlyn the the
structure
uh of a loan that's what makes most
sense given what we're balancing here
which is helping our global partners
while they have a critical need and we
await
the results of the clinical trials here
in the u.s
and fda action on astrazeneca in the
next several weeks
so this arrangement helps canada and mec
mexico in the moment meet that critical
need while ensuring that they
return those doses uh through the
company through astrazeneca
later in the year dr wolinski great yeah
thank you caitlyn for that question
first let me just acknowledge um what
the teachers have had to do this year in
the context of covet 19 and how
they have had to evolve their thinking
and their curricula
and how they teach their students and
through truly an overwhelming and
challenging time
i've spoken to the teachers unions um
they know that we need to follow the
science and to make our guidance based
on that science
and they've been very respectful of that
next question next we'll go to kristen
welker at nbc
hi everyone thanks for doing the call um
can you address the fact that there has
been an
uptick in cases in some states new
jersey new york rhode island
to name just a few why do you assess
this is happening now given the fact
that people
are getting vaccinated and how concerned
are you about it
and can you just be crystal clear why is
it
okay for kids to be three feet apart
but adults in the workplace for example
still
need to be six feet apart thank you
so let's have dr fauci answer the first
question about
increases in some states and dr valensky
3 versus 16 dr
fauci yeah thank you very much jeff yes
that's an excellent question and it
really relates to what we have been
saying
on the past few briefings that we've
given
we're at a position right now where we
have a plateauing at around 53
000 cases per day the concern is
that throughout the country there are a
number of state city regions
that are pulling back on some of the
mitigation
methods that we've been talking about
the withdrawal of mass
mandates the pulling back to essentially
non-uh public health measures being
implemented
this is something that each of us have
expressed
concerned about that is really quite
risky to declare
victory before you have the level of
infection in the community to a much
much
lower level than 53 000
cases per day so it is unfortunate but
not surprising to me
that you are seeing increases in
number of cases per day in
areas cities states or regions
even though vaccines are being
distributed
at a pretty good clip of two to three
million per day
that could be overcome if certain
areas pull back prematurely
on the mitigation and public health
measures that we all talk about
maybe i'll time and um thank you for
that question kristen that the
evidence shows that the risk of cova 19
transmission among younger children is
much lower than it is
among teenagers and adults and in
particular our school studies have shown
that when children young children are
masked
the distance of three feet is in fact
safe and has a lower transmission risk
for adults we don't have that evidence
and and for older children
and so we're continuing with the
six-foot guidance
i just want to reiterate what the
president said yesterday which is
consistent with what our theology just
said which is
it is a time for optimism
but not a time for relaxation we need to
follow
the basic public health standards
we need to mask up and then we need to
make sure everyone gets their vaccine
when it's their turn
we cannot let down our guard at this
point
kevin one more question one more
question we'll go to april ryan with
degrio
thank you for letting me ask this
question what are the concerns with
the variant uh and its severity as it
relates to school-aged
children we're understanding that the
variants are hitting uh the children
harder than the original strain and how
does this play into
these new guidelines uh for schools in
the distancing three feet apart
thank you let's start with dr fauci on
the variant in kids and then over to you
dr wolinski
well yes obviously as i mentioned in one
of the first slides that i showed
that there is an increase in severity
but also it appears
that the likelihood of a child getting
infected is greater with this very that
might relate not to anything
specific about children but that it is
just in general
more easily transmitted so that would
explain that
regarding the school situation i'll hand
that back to
dr wolenski and what we can say is that
it is in fact
while these variants are concerning it
is in fact the same disease and the same
mitigation strategies the masking the
distancing work just the same um with
with the variances they do within wild
type disease
good well thank you everybody
for uh joining us we'll look forward to
monday's briefing thank you
you